Game of Thrones Season 8 Episode 3 is The
Long Night – the army of the dead attacks
Winterfell.
The living are Daenerys and Jon with the dragons,
the Dothraki and Unsullied, armies of the
north Vale and wildlings, and almost every
other living character.
Bran is with Theon in the godswood, cause
the plan is to lure the Night King and kill
him to end the war.
So the whole gang’s here, fighting to save
the world.
And they use some questionable battle tactics
.
Their trebuchets are in front of their defences,
so they only get to fire once before they’re
overwhelmed and useless.
The infantry are in front of the trenches,
so the trenches don’t protect them, in fact
they get in the way of the retreat.
You’d think everyone shoulda just stayed
in Winterfell, defending the castle, cause
that’s what castles are for.
There are lots of weird tactics this episode,
made for the sake of heightening the drama.
Melisandre arrives.
She left for Volantis last season , and some
fans hoped she’d return with an army, or
other red priests.
Melisandre doesn’t bring allies, but she
does bring fire magic, setting alight the
Dothraki weapons.
It sure is lucky she came, because those Dothraki
arakhs aren’t Valyrian steel or dragonglass,
so they would’ve been pretty useless against
the dead if Mel hadn’t shown up.
Melisandre’s confronted by Davos – he
once promised to execute Mel because she burned
his friend Shireen.
She says there’s no need to kill her because
she’ll die tonight.
There’s this great shot of Melisandre’s
shadow in the light – Melisandre believes
in just good and evil, black and white with
nothing in-between . But ironically, Melisandre
is one of the most morally grey characters
in the series – she does great things and
terrible things, and everything in between.
The Dothraki charge, lights in the darkness
like stars – that blink out one by one as
the Dothraki die.
It’s a terrifying apocalyptic image that
also evokes Dothraki religion.
The Dothraki believe that when they die, their
spirit becomes a star , riding a fiery horse
across the night sky . The more fiercely a
man burns in life, the brighter his star shines
. So it’s all the more horrifying that these
fiery Dothraki are extinguished in pitch darkness.
The showrunners say this is “the end of
the Dothraki” – which is a pretty bleak
end to their journey.
Daenerys spent whole seasons winning the trust
of the Dothraki.
She learned to be a Khaleesi, and led her
khalasar through the Red Waste.
In Season 6, she returned to the Dothraki
and gathered a massive army, declaring them
all her personal blood riders , to cross the
seas and conquer as no other Dothraki had
– to be hers “Now and always” . But
ten minutes in to this battle, they’re all
dead.
We never got to see the Dothraki perspective
on foreign Westeros, or how the Dothraki habit
of burning and raiding would fit in Dany’s
regime.
There weren’t even any named Dothraki this
season – unless you count Qhono, and no
one counts Qhono.
So this is a sad sudden end to the people
who shaped so much of Daenerys’ story.
The plan is to keep the dragons out of combat
until the Night King comes , but when Dany
sees the Dothraki die, she abandons the plan,
and she and Jon burn some zombies, as they
should’ve from the start.
Jon tries to attack the white walkers who
lead the dead, but the walkers conjure a storm
that blows him back – similar to the storm
at Hardhome.
The dead crash into the living like an unstoppable
force of nature.
Jaime Brienne Pod Tormund Beric Hound Gendry
Sam and Edd are all on the front lines, and
somehow they all survive this – except for
Edd, which is just his luck.
RIP to the 999th Lord Commander of the Night’s
Watch.
The fighters realise that that castle thing
was a good idea after all, so they retreat
into Winterfell, while the Unsullied hold
back the dead.
The Unsullied are uniquely qualified for this
sort of thing.
In Game of Thrones history, a group of three
thousand Unsullied famously held off an army
of Dothraki at Qohor.
Twenty thousand Dothraki broke on the Unsullied
“like waves on a rocky shore” . So the
Unsullied are good this, but they can only
last so long against the dead.
So Grey Worm closes the trench behind his
men, sacrificing them.
So very early in this battle, most of Daenerys’
army is destroyed – her Dothraki and Unsullied
are mostly gone.
So afterwards, she’ll need the support of
the north more than ever.
The living try to the light the trench with
fiery torches – it’s a like a reverse
of Helm’s Deep from Lord of the Rings.
The torches fail, so Melisandre steps up.
Mel had a crisis of faith after Stannis died
in Season 5.
She regained some confidence when she resurrected
Jon.
And now, she calls on her god to give her
fire, and the trenches light.
So Melisandre is filled with faith – she
believes her god has a plan.
In the godswood, Bran uses his warging powers
to control some ravens, and he flies them
up to the Night King, on his zombie dragon.
It’s unclear if Bran is trying to get the
Night King’s attention, or if he’s just
having a look-see, or what, but Bran spends
the rest of the battle in warg-mode, doing
nothing that we can see.
Which seems like a waste of his powers.
Bran spent six seasons learning magic to fight
the walkers – and now he’s not using any?
He doesn’t warg a dragon, or have some important
vision, or tell anyone anything useful?
It seems like Bran knows the future, he knows
how this battle will end, and he’s just
sitting and watching while destiny runs it
course.
So it’s pretty underwhelming that the culmination
of Bran’s training is him being bait – a
MacGuffin on wheels.
Did Jojen and Hodor and Bran’s personality
die for this?
The dead are held back by the fiery trench,
but the Night King orders them to form a bridge
of corpses.
Part of why the wights are scary is that they
have human bodies, but no humanity – they’re
just mindless machines with no self-preservation,
and no mercy.
The dead assault the walls, and the heroes
hack and slash.
A bunch of times, we see characters facing
certain death, covered in wights, but then
someone saves them with one sword-stoke, or
the camera just cuts, and it’s scary the
first few times, but it’s soon clear that
none of the main characters are in danger.
Lyanna Mormont, the young Lady of Bear Isle,
dies killing a wight giant.
Lyanna had always talked big talk.
Now, she follows through with action, giving
her life to defend the north.
There are hints in the books that Tormund
might be Lyanna’s father – go watch that
video.
So it’s cool that last episode, Tormund
claimed to have killed a giant . Now, his
possible daughter Lyanna has also killed a
giant – must run in the family.
The Hound freaks out – he’s afraid of
fire, since his brother the Mountain burned
his face.
In Season 2, the Hound ran from the Battle
of Blackwater because of this fear.
But when the Hound sees Arya in trouble, he
overcomes his fear, and rushes to help her.
So again, Arya inspires the Hound be a braver
better man.
Arya does some sick ninja moves, using all
her training with the Faceless Men – they
taught her to fight with staffs, and in the
dark.
But she takes a blow to the head, and retreats
to the Winterfell library for a stealth section,
like the kitchen scene in Jurrasic Park.
She silently kills a wight, and gently lowers
it to the ground.
This is an intimate dance with death.
Arya’s arc is all about the deaths of her
friends, the deaths of her enemies – now
she gets dangerously close to her own death
. When she’s overwhelmed, the Hound and
Beric save her.
Beric gives up his last life, sacrificing
himself in a Jesus T-pose.
Beric believed the Lord of Light had a special
plan for him, and that’s why he was resurrected
six times.
Turns out Beric’s destiny was to save Arya.
You’d think that god could’ve cut out
the middle-man and just resurrected Arya if
needed – but since when were gods efficient?
Arya sees Melisandre – they met before,
in Season 3.
Melisandre had told Arya she would shut many
eyes forever – including “blue eyes”
. She also reminds Arya of something Syrio
said – “What do we say to the God of Death?”,
“Not today” . So Mel is hinting that Arya’s
destiny is to kill the Night King, the blue-eyed
embodiment of death.
Of course, these scenes were shot before the
showrunners decided to have Arya kill the
Night King, so they’re sorta retconned into
seeming relevant – Melisandre changes the
wording of the eyes quote to emphasise the
blue eyes . The series spent seven seasons
setting up Jon and Dany as the forces to beat
the white walkers.
But now at the last minute they shoehorn Arya
in as though she was foreshadowed from the
start.
In the skies, the dragons dance.
There hasn’t been a dragon fight in Westeros
for over a hundred years, and there’s never
been a fight with a zombie dragon.
Daenerys’ dragon wounds the zombie dragon
Viserion, ripping off half his face.
But Jon’s dragon Rhaegal is also hurt, and
crashes with Jon to the ground.
Daenerys’ dragon burns the Night King, but
he’s unhurt, and smirks like an anime villain.
Jon chases the Night King on foot, so the
Night King raises all the dead as zombies.
Edd, Lyanna and Qhono all rise to fight their
former allies, which would be much scarier
if these guys were important characters.
Jon is completely surrounded by zombies, but
when the camera cuts back, he’s fine.
Jon has survived so many unsurvivable situations
lately that it’s getting hard to care when
he’s in danger.
Daenerys lands her dragon, and it’s swarmed
by zombies, like ants over a lizard.
Daenerys falls off Drogon – she should really
strap herself on to a saddle, like the old
Targaryens did.
Jorah’s khaleesi-sense tingles, and he rushes
to help her.
Jorah ultimately dies protecting Daenerys,
which is about the best death he could’ve
hoped for.
He’s always been defined by his loyalty
to his khaleesi, so he dies as he lived.
Meanwhile, Tyrion Sansa Missandei Varys and
Gilly hide in the crypts.
Tyrion wants to help the battle somehow, but
Sansa says they can’t do anything, so they
don’t.
Tyrion jokes that he and Sansa should’ve
stayed married, but Sansa says it wouldn’t
work because of Tyrion’s “divided loyalties”
– he’s more loyal to Daenerys than to
the Starks.
The show seems to be setting up conflict between
Daenerys’ squad and Jon’s, and Tyrion
is at its centre.
When the Night King raises the dead, the dead
Starks in the crypts also rise – who would’ve
thought that a room full of corpses would
be dangerous with an icy necromancer on the
loose.
Sansa and Tyrion share a moment of tenderness,
holding dragonglass daggers.
Some viewers saw this like they were about
to kill themselves, but a behind-the-scenes
feature suggests they’re actually about
fight the zombies in some cut footage.
The living are overwhelmed by the dead, and
Jon tries to get to Bran.
He sees Sam almost killed by wights, but doesn’t
help him, which in bird culture is considered
a dick more.
Jon ends up pinned by the wounded zombie dragon.
Fire streams from its neck, where it was bit
by Drogon.
The walkers reach the godswood, and Theon
is the last ironborn standing.
Bran tells Theon that he’s a good man , and
that Winterfell is his home . All Theon ever
wanted was a home, and a family that accepted
him.
That tension is what led him to betray the
Starks, and take Winterfell from Bran.
But now Bran forgives him.
Theon finally gets his redemption, and is
killed by the Night King.
In Book 5, Theon stands in this godswood and
prays for a sword – “Let me die as Theon,
not as Reek” . Now, he gets his wish.
The Night King approaches Bran in ultra slow
motion – he’s waited eight thousand years
for this, so like any super villain, he takes
his sweet time.
He and Bran and represent powerful magic forces
– Bran the three-eyed raven holds the world’s
memory and history, whatever that means, and
the Night King is an ancient weapon who turned
on his creators, the children of the forest.
Just as he’s about to kill Bran, Arya leaps
out of nowhere and attacks.
The Night King catches Arya, but she drops
her dagger into her off hand, and stabs the
Night King – in the same place where the
dragonglass that created him was stabbed.
Arya’s Valyrian knife was originally used
in an attempt on Bran’s life – now Arya
uses the knife to save Bran’s life.
And the knife has a much older history – Sam
once found a book connecting the knife to
the ancient Targaryens who took Westeros three
hundred years ago.
The showrunners hinted that the hilt of this
blade is made from the same chunk of dragonglass
that created the Night King – and so he
was unmade by the same dragonglass that created
him .
The Night King is destroyed, and all his walkers
and wights also fall – like in the Phantom
Menace.
Arya ends the Great War, and Melisandre walks
out into the dawn.
She dedicated her life to winning this war.
She is hundreds of years old, essentially
a slave to her god.
Now, with her purpose finally fulfilled, she
lets herself rest.
She reverts to her true ancient form, and
dies in the snow.
So this episode brings a neat end the arcs
of Melisandre, Theon and Jorah.
But what does it mean for the main characters,
and the white walkers, and Game of Thrones
itself?
In recent seasons, there’s a lot of foreshadowing
leading up to Arya killing the Night King
in the godswood.
Bran gave Arya her Valyrian knife in the godswood
last season, and you can tell he had a special
purpose in mind.
Then Arya sneaks up on Jon in the godswood
, just as she sneaks up on the Night King.
And Arya uses the same hand-switching trick
with the knife on Brienne that she uses on
the Night King.
Arya trained for seasons to be a stealthy
deadly assassin.
Her story is about death, and the Night King
is the embodiment of death.
Maybe now that she’s killed him, Arya can
let go of her vengeance quest, and reconnect
with her humanity.
So from the perspective of Arya’s story,
her killing the Night King makes sense.
But what does it mean for Jon and Dany?
It’s clear from the start that Jon and Daenerys
are central to the magic and prophecy in this
story – the song of ice and fire.
Daenerys was miraculously reborn unburnt with
dragons beneath a bleeding star.
Jon Snow was resurrected like Christ, he’s
been fighting the dead since Season 1, and
he’s faced off the Night King repeatedly.
Jon and Dany both come from the ancient magic
Targaryen bloodline, and there’s a prophecy
hinting that they will save the world from
the white walkers, with some magic sacrifice.
The show doesn’t mention the prophecy stuff
as much as the books do, but it’s still
heavily hinted that defeating the walkers
is Jon and Dany’s destiny.
So it’s pretty crazy that Jon and Dany not
only don’t kill the Night King, but they’re
barely involved in the end – like, while
Arya saves the world, Dany’s crying over
Ser Friendzone, and Jon is.. yelling at a
dragon.
It’s not clear if Jon and Dany really helped
beat the walkers at all.
Like, yeah they gathered the armies and helped
fight the dead, but that was always a losing
battle , just a ploy to lure the Night King
. If Jon and Dany weren’t there at all,
the Night King still would’ve come for Bran,
and Arya still could’ve killed him, right?
Jon and Dany represent the song of ice and
fire, yet they played only minor roles in
its climax.
The showrunners said they had Arya kill the
Night King because it was unexpected . And
Game of Thrones has always had surprising
twists – like when the ‘main character’
Ned Stark died in Season 1.
And the deaths of Catelyn and Robb at the
Red Wedding.
But those twists had meaning.
They showed how honour and love can get you
killed in a world of treacherous politics.
What’s the meaning of Arya jumping from
nowhere to kill the Night King?
That it’s cool to be a ninja?
That Arya’s dehumanising murderous hate-fuelled
quest was good?
And where does that leave Jon and Daenerys?
If their destiny isn’t about beating the
white walkers, what is it about?
Taking the Iron Throne?
The whole point of the walkers is to show
that the Throne is irrelevant – human greed
and pride will just lead to our self-destruction.
The walkers are an apocalyptic threat that
forces humanity to abandon their power struggles
and unite – the north, the wildlings, and
Daenerys came together to face a true enemy.
But suddenly, that’s all over in Episode
3 – so will Jon and Dany now fight another
yet war for the Throne, against Cersei?
Why include the white walkers in the story
if they’re just a stepping stone to more
human war and petty politics?
Was the ancient ice demon apocalypse just
a warmup for the war against a drunk queen
and her pal the horny pirate?
Thrones author George Martin says his series
will end like the Lord of the Rings books,
with the Scouring of the Shire.
In the final chapters of Rings, after the
good guys beat Sauron, the hobbits return
to the Shire and have to deal with Saruman.
It’s a bittersweet epilogue that shows that
the world is saved, but it’s also changed,
and its heroes have too.
Maybe Thrones will do something similar.
The big bad white walkers are defeated, but
taking Cersei off the Throne will be a time
to reflect on how the last eight seasons have
scarred Westeros and its people.
But there are three long episodes left – and
if they’re filled with more big battles
and power struggles, that would undercut the
whole point of the walkers as a metaphor for
how terrible and pointless war is.
We also learned nothing new about the white
walkers – no great revelations of their
motivations or origins.
Nothing about these spirals, or the babies,
or the deeper mysteries hinted in the books.
And maybe that’s fine – the white walkers
aren’t characters, they’re a device.
Like zombies in other stories, their purpose
is to push the human characters to extremes,
to show what they’re really made of, and
make them do extraordinary things.
But in this episode, the main characters did
nothing new.
Jon and Daenerys were brave.
Arya was badass.
Tyrion drank wine.
Bran was confusing.
We did get neat conclusions for Theon and
Jorah and Beric and Mel – but these are
secondary characters.
You’d think the final confrontation with
the ultimate bad guys should’ve brought
out something climactic from the main characters.
You’d also think that at least one main
character would have died.
But in the end, the white walkers just didn’t
impact the story that much.
Walder Frey killed more important characters
than the Night King did.
All the walkers really was bring Jon and Daenerys
together.
And if Jon and Dany’s alliance just leads
to more war, it’s hard to see the point
of the walkers.
And sure, maybe there’ll be a twist.
Maybe the Night King will respawn at the spiral
tree for Round 2, and some climax with Jon
and Dany will happen after all.
Maybe Bran was up to something with his magic
– we still dunno what he was doing all battle,
or what his arc is meant to mean.
We’ll just have to wait and see.
Game of Thrones ends in a few weeks.
The Game of Thrones books go deep into prophecy,
with intricate hints and symbolism.
But we’re also warned against prophecy.
One of the coolest characters in the books
who doesn’t appear in the show is Marwyn
the Mage, a sort of rogue professor, a paranoid
maverick maester.
He talks about the prophecy of Azor Ahai,
that hints that Jon or Daenerys will beat
the white walkers, and he says he doesn’t
trust it.
He compares prophecy to a “treacherous woman”
who gives “pleasure” until “her teeth
snap shut” – “That is the nature of
prophecy … Prophecy will bite your prick
off every time” . You can hear all about
Marwyn and Azor Ahai for free today by signing
up for a trial with Audible.
Members get a book each month, and if you
cancel, you keep the books.
You can read in the car or the gym or while
you chill out and wait for your sister to
save the world.
Sign up at audible.com/asx.
Thanks for watching.
We’re holding livestreams right after each
episode of Thrones, and Patreon supporters
can watch past livestreams.
Thanks to Patrons Peter Meehan, Emily McNally,
sandra lange, Marian, Patrick Long, Robert
Gane, and Kewl0210.
Cheers.